This video is sponsored by
Audible.
Listen to a free audiobook and 2 Audible Originals
with the link in the description.
Singapore is not known for its subtlety.
From the minute you land and see the world’s
tallest indoor waterfall inside the airport,
you’re inundated with beautiful, clean,
and green architecture.
The sight of extraordinary, lush buildings
is so common that it almost becomes boring.
All the rest, though, pale in comparison to
one.
What the Eiffel Tower is to Paris, or the
Opera house to Sydney, the Marina Bay Sands
is to Singapore.
You just can’t visit without taking a photo.
In this one, small, resort area is the famous
Gardens By The Bay, Flower Dome, Cloud Forest,
outdoor event piazza, convention center, theater,
art and science museum, luxury mall, two floating
crystal pavilions, and, finally, 3-tower,
55-story hotel, with the world’s highest
pool on top.
Altogether, the Marina Bay Sands resort cost
$5.5 billion, making it the 5th most expensive
building in the world.
Perhaps the only subtle thing about it, is,
oddly enough, also, the reason it was built:
the casino.
Singapore has long been a popular destination
for tourism.
Beyond its use of English - far more than
its closest competitor, Hong Kong, it’s
also well-known for its beauty, lack of crime,
and cleanliness.
As an aviation hub with one of the world’s
best airlines, it’s also cheap and easy
for Asian travelers to get to.
From Bangkok, 116 US Dollars, roundtrip, on
average, and 2 hours and 15 minutes, $219
and 4 hours and 44 minutes from Taipei, and
$318, and 8 hours, a quick hop, relatively
speaking, from Sydney.
But, back in the early 2000s, Singapore found
itself losing to its many regional competitors.
It’s share of tourism in the Asia-Pacific
region shrunk from 13.1% in 1991, to just
5.8% by 2004.
This, was attributed, in part, to its lack
of natural physical attractions, a symptom
of its small size.
Today, Singapore has only 1 of the 1,121 total
UNESCO World Heritage Sites, its Botanical
Gardens, and, at the time, none.
Neighboring Malaysia, meanwhile, has 4, Vietnam,
8, and Thailand, 5.
All three of which are well-known, inexpensive
destinations.
To stay competitive and revive its national
image, the Singapore government surprised
everyone in 2004 when it floated the radical
idea of legalizing casinos, four decades after
making them illegal.
Culturally, casino gambling was considered
destructive and fundamentally at odds with
the country’s very conservative mentality
and willingness to ban or regulate just about
anything.
Social and religious groups protested, a rare
sight in authoritarian Singapore, and 30,000
people signed a petition in opposition.
“Casi-No” bumper stickers could be seen
on cars and hundreds of polls, surveys, and
dialogues were held.
It soon became known that the city-state’s
then 4 million people were roughly evenly
divided on the issue, and calls were made
for a referendum - an indicator of how passionate
the public had become.
Then, in April of 2005, just 13 months later,
it was all over.
The government announced it would allow the
construction of not one but 2 casino resorts
- one in the centrally-located Marina Bay,
and the other on its southern island of Sentosa.
For comparison, Sydney debated the merits
of opening casinos for a full 6 years.
But, for the Singaporean government, this
quick, effective, and sometimes contradictory
decision making, is characteristic.
In 1987, for example, its family planning
slogan was changed from “Stop at two”
directly to “Have 3 or more if you can afford
it”.
In any case, the government had made up its
mind and began soliciting Request for Concepts
from interested bidders.
Importantly, the government invented the now-popular
term “Integrated Resort” to describe a
single development with an attached hotel,
convention center, entertainment, theme parks,
luxury retail shops, fine dining, and yes,
a casino.
This was its billion-dollar hint to bidders
- although they were interested, first and
foremost, in developing one of Singapore’s
first casinos, they were to be designed as
iconic and symbolic national landmarks.
Of the 19 submitted proposals, 14 were shortlisted,
and 4 continued with formal bids.
Finally, in May 2006, the Las Vegas Sands
Corporation was selected for Marina Bay, thanks
to its proven success in Nevada and Macau.
Also crucial was the architect - Israeli,
Moshe Safdie, who, at age 27, had designed
Montreal’s famous Habitat 67.
Safdie’s impressive proposal for a 3-tower
block design was cleverly modeled after playing
cards.
Each of the three towers would be composed
of two structures - one flat, and one curved
ten times more than the Leaning Tower of Pisa.
This unique concept breaks conventional rules
of architecture in that higher floors actually
become larger and larger, until they reach
the hotel’s three, most expensive and luxurious,
“Chairman Suites”.
As if not ambitious enough, there was only
a 27-month window for construction, which
required a 4-day cycle, meaning an entire
floor would need to be completed every four
days to stay on track.
The Singapore government argued that a hotel
this grand deserved an equally impressive
pool.
It was decided that a three-acre, 340-meter
long park would be built on top, complete
with jogging paths, four swimming pools, an
observation deck, promenade, restaurants,
spa, and 900 species of plants.
Called the SkyPark, it resembled a ship sailing
above Singapore.
Beautiful as it was, the park presented several
significant challenges.
First, how to get it up.
Ultimately, the hull was constructed on the
ground in 14 sections, then lifted into place,
at a slow, safe speed of 46 feet per hour.
16 hours to lift each segment all the way.
Second, as infinity pools, the water needed
to flow evenly to create the illusion of falling
off the top.
This, despite the fact that the 380,000-gallon
pools also laid on top of three 55-story towers
which would sink over time as their foundations
shifted, each at a different rate, and all
susceptible to wind.
To protect against this, four joints were
placed beneath each pool, capable of moving
up to 500 millimeters to offset any changes.
Getting the pool from Indiana took more than
30 cargo ships, and the park alone was, itself,
a $150 million project.
When it soft-opened in 2010, the Marina Bay
Sands was neither the world’s, nor Singapore’s
tallest building.
Rather, it turns heads for somehow being somewhat
absurd, fantastic, and iconic, all at the
same time.
It’s one of those few buildings which retains
its beauty no matter the angle, vantage point,
or time of day.
Inside the hotel, visitors are greeted with
a stunning hollow atrium.
The pools create the sensation of swimming
on top of skyscrapers.
While the other side of the SkyPark offers
a view of the garden and endless flow of container
ships passing through the strait.
The attached mall, with its indoor canal,
is somehow just as impressive.
Further south is Resorts World Sentosa.
It features a more family-friendly environment
with an aquarium, water park, Universal Studios,
wax museum, hotel complex, and Singapore’s
other casino.
Although less architecturally impressive,
Resorts World Sentosa is remarkable for its
sheer density of attractions.
Unsurprisingly, both locations have been hugely
successful.
The Marina Bay Sands has quickly become the
world’s most profitable casino and been
a huge source of growth for the Singapore
economy.
As of 2018, the tiny city-state receives more
international visitors than New York, Dubai,
or Paris, and only fewer than Macau, London,
Bangkok, and Hong Kong.
This was and is the best case for legalizing
casinos - here, or anywhere.
Proponents argue it’s “easy money” - that
there’s no faster way to create wealth out
of thin air.
Amazingly, Singapore’s two resorts contribute
between 1.5 and 2% of its entire GDP.
They create an estimated 20,000 jobs directly
- in the form of dealers, inspectors, hotel
staff, entertainers, cashiers, slot attendants
and so on, and an additional 30-40,000, indirectly.
Not only do they attract more tourists, but
also higher quality - business travelers and
VIPs.
On the other hand, some are skeptical of the
economic benefits, suggesting increased tax
revenue is offset by increased expenditures
in the form of enforcement, infrastructure,
and, not to be forgotten, the social costs
of casinos.
While the majority of Singaporeans admit to
gambling themselves, in some form, most also
believe casinos are unique in the way they
encourage addiction.
Their interiors are designed with the express
intent of keeping players inside as long as
possible, which, for a small minority, leads
to pathological behavior.
This tiny group of people then disproportionately
cost their communities in the form of lost
productivity, bankruptcy, crime, welfare,
and, of course, the suffering of their families.
Casinos, unlike races or cruises, are available
24/7.
It’s said that a casino within 10 miles
of a person’s home leads to a 90% increase
in the odds of that person becoming a pathological
gambler.
One 2005 study also estimated such a person
costs themselves and their community $19,711
on average, a year.
Casinos also target specific culturally vulnerable
groups.
For instance, by adhering closely to Feng
Shui principles to play on superstition.
Still others, accept a combination of these
arguments.
They argue that players will travel to wherever
gambling is available - the only question
is whether to capture their spending locally.
In the U.S., for example, states are more
likely to legalize casinos when their neighbors
do first.
In Singapore, gamblers have always had easy
access in Malaysia, Indonesia, and on cruises.
This was one of the primary rationales for
Singapore’s decision back in 2005 - why
not benefit from what’s already going to
happen?
But, although it would do the unthinkable
and open the door to casinos, it would do
so in a uniquely Singaporean way.
While every other gambling hub in the world
flaunts its casinos for all they’re worth,
Singapore has been very careful to balance
profit with the attendant social costs - arguably,
at great expense.
From the very beginning, the National Development
commission stipulated the casino could not
occupy more than 3-5% of the total resort
space.
The original plan for a strong Venetian theme
and monorail connecting the casino to the
ferry terminal were later replaced, at the
insistence of the government, with the SkyPark
and pool.
The resort is also the company’s only property
where the location precedes the “Sands”
brand in its name - a subtle reflection of
the projects’ focus.
The original architect, an expert in casino
design, was later replaced with Safdie, who
was instead known for impressive and unique
architecture.
The two gaps between the building’s three
towers grant a view of the sea beyond it.
It complements rather than intrudes on the
skyline, in contrast to most casinos.
In practice, this means the Marina Bay Sands
is neither as tacky as Vegas or shady as Macau.
It’s an immediate, iconic, symbol of Singapore.
You might spend hours shopping, eating, swimming,
even stay at the hotel, but aside for the
occasional sign, you may not even notice the
existence of the casino - where the company
makes roughly 70% of its profit.
For its part, the government has also taken
tangible steps to reduce problematic behavior.
Family members can request their loved ones
be barred from gambling, those under 21 are
forbidden from entering casinos, and ATMs
are not available inside the gambling areas.
Most significantly, Singapore residents are
required to pay an entry fee of $150 or $3,000
per year to access each resort - neither of
which are allowed to refund or reimburse that
fee.
Today, ten years after their grand openings,
most people would say Singapore has succeeded
- it’s reaped the economic benefits while,
at the same time, managing the effects.
Still, in hiding its casinos, it runs the
risk of also hiding their damage, their casualties,
their hardships.
By taxing dubious behavior, Singapore not
only deters it and profits from it, but also
risks economically depending on it.
After Singapore is sanitized, making itself
clean, green, and its vices, unseen, it’s
easy to forget what’s lost.
If casinos, economics, and the economics of
casinos interest you, you’re going to love
my upcoming 30-minute documentary about a
very related topic.
I’ve been saying this for a while, but this
time, I promise, it’s written, recorded,
and coming quite soon.
In the meantime, you should listen to the
also related story of how two mathematicians
applied their genius to the game of blackjack,
and then used their knowledge to win on wall
street.
This story, called “Fortune’s Formula”
has just about everything that interests me:
economics, business, finance, and a fascinating
narrative, and you can listen to it, along
with thousands of other audiobooks, with Audible.
Audible is so easy for me to recommend because
I religiously listen to so many audiobooks
myself.
You can listen to them in the shower, on the
way to work or school, or while playing video
games.
You can download them for offline with their
free mobile apps and membership gives you
access to any 1 audiobook a month plus two
Audible Originals.
Go to my link in the description - Audible.com/polymatter
- that’s A-U-D-I-B-L-E.COM/P-O-L-Y-M-A-T-T-E-R
or text p-o-l-y-m-a-t-t-e-r to 500-500 for
a 30-day free trial.
Thanks to Audible for sponsoring this video
and to you for watching.